yep he is their team's best three-point
shooter submit eights beautiful move and
finished Simmons in the open floor
must line Barz whistles remain silent
Ben keeps his head about him and gets
his second bucket I don't think that's
too far of a stretch both both big guys
deserve some recognition
Simmons again you can't sit for cues
supporting his case look at Big Ben's
herd in that corner it's Amir who sets
that screen a little bit of contact
there I think there's less contact on
this play than there was on the last
Drive player in the league right now Joe
Cheon the Rockets and given the amount
of basketball played the amount the
government's focus on it is to do more
good players and I think the problem is
that there isn't a system for tonight
everything he's had has been in the
painted area via the dribble or steals
and finishes
a steal by covington Simmons took
bobbington
personal bounce six are suddenly by
eighteen and be his third block on the
first half he runs the floor with
Simmons and finishes what he
take a look at the sixes on defense we
talked about the great rotation
defending without Ally hit that right
back to the big boy
he's running the court for you four
years at 106.5 million and the Wizards
matched beautifully down there that's
Thunder going to Lightning Sixers here
in the first 24 sorry oh Sh orange
neatly done compliments event Simmons
prevent by the way pounds lighter but
Gortat used to the banging down low has
his way by the way Amir Johnson full
time in the second half for him Simmons
off his own this pick it up Simmons did
so after the Beal miss Bradley Beal just
2 of 6
Huntington launching a three and down it
goes for Robert Covington to his third
straight Bobby out for at least another
week and a half
Simmons a dark just move in
around behind me I could have used to
say both I don't know why I went with
Carl Ertz
I could have totally used you say both a
sprinter comparison right and he
sustained in the lost couple of nights
go to Cleveland
tonight's miss by Amir Johnson to submit